[Music]
hello
thanks keep up the good work
what do you think impressive huh did you
find out what it's made of
as a matter of fact it's water the
exoskeleton absorbs carbon dioxide
for regeneration some sort of
biotechnology
some sort of photosynthesis hello
professor hello
hey how long is he going to be in there
another 10 more minutes comment general
he can hear us
our engineers integrated a radio headset
into the exoskeleton
a russian extraterrestrial co-production
welcome yuya
shall we begin
i'm ready what did you feel
when you knew this spacecraft crashed in
the city
nothing i was unconscious
they rescued me okay and then
when you knew that your friend had been
killed
what is it that we usually feel when
someone close to us dies
julia please try to keep still we don't
want to compromise the results
of the experiment and then you wanted to
take revenge
is that right i can't remember
take a look at her heartbeat and then
you decided
quite specifically to help the creature
why was that
i've already told you a thousand times
you want to hear it again
her negative emotions generate a
significant upsurge in the waves see it
about your boyfriend artion
what happened between you two
we broke up that's it
can you tell me why did you do it
because of the alien
at what point did you start having
feelings for him
am i required to answer
we've all been hoping for some sort of a
breakthrough
i'm sorry to keep repeating this but
julie is all we have if we could only do
some proper testing
i should let you treat yulia like she
was some kind of a rat for testing
[Music]
yulia can you tell me why you decided to
help the alien
at what point did you start having
feelings for him
do i have to answer they're back again
you you're in danger
you all went too far in your research we
have to get out of here
you can come back
but she must be eliminated so this is a
cyber attack but not from this planet
you know i don't belong here dad
everything's gonna be fine
i don't even have a passport are we
gonna cross the border we'll have to
cook up a corruption scam
no more cell phones no more digital
[Music]
technology
[Music]
help me
[Music]
[Music]
you